a couple weeks ago I suggested that we
use webcam technology to allow a viewer
at home to actually fit sit in our
audience we thought this would be a cool
innovation in the talk-show world so we
set up a laptop here in the studio and
the viewer then could be part of our
studio audience without leaving home
this may be the wave of the future right
no one everyone will just be laptops
yeah you'll all just be watching it will
this be sitting here eating nachos right
right yeah I don't know why that follows
but it does anyway we had an online
contest and we finally selected winner
her name is Aidan Zorich and she goes to
Penn State and she's been with us since
the very beginning of the show watching
everything hello there Aidan how you
doing I'm great where are you right now
Aidan can you tell us where you are okay
you're at your home and Youngstown Ohio
now yesterday we were gonna do this and
you were in your dorm at Penn State is
that correct yeah you have a tiny room
but all of your friends came and they
had all their wireless devices and it
destroyed our connection you remember
that yeah remember how that ruined
everything
yeah ruined your whole night but you're
with us now you've kicked your friends
out and you're in a secure location is
this the room where you grew up right
now yeah it looks amazing that's cool I
like your your your your decor can you
show us around a little bit you just
what's that like I like that cool chair
behind you is very neat yeah yeah it's
okay you don't have to move anything
around you're you're fine I just I'm
just admiring your room that's all in a
creepy pervy way where do you keep your
clothes Aidan Aidan you brought you know
by now that I'm kind of a creep don't
you hmm okay Aidan I think that was an
answer yes hey Aidan let's see what your
view looks like I'm curious you're
actually watching the show oh look at
that
there's eight
[Applause]
Wow
what a terrible view of the show good
enough yeah she's like whatevs
that's your whole generation Aiden
whatevs right whatevs
have you been watching the show so far
yeah have you enjoyed it no did you say
you did not enjoy the show so far Aiden
I'm kidding I like wet myself
he's a fragile man Aiden be here yeah
you have no idea
especially your equipment I'm like so
needy no no I you've watched the show I
think you also have watched some
rehearsal too haven't you mmm yeah you
so you got to see our process yeah it's
awesome
no no I'm weird too at rehearsal I get
really weird we're all in an altered
state
yeah herself so we've been doing the
show for a while now Aidan and I'm just
curious did you I don't think her view
is very good by the way I'm just sure it
curious can you see me now is this a
better view for you
should I just do the rest of the show
like this Aiden this is so much better
cool
want to go out tonight you smiling you
talked about yesterday what's that you
getting in again oh yeah being creepy
yeah um Aiden did you like The Human
Centipede menorah I'm just really happy
I didn't win that contest
Aiden those people lost a contest